my name is Monty winow and I'm a
assistant professor in the department of
genetics at Stanford and I've been here
for about 3 years I did my PhD in
Immunology program at Stanford before
moving to Boston for 5 years where I
actually switched from Immunology to
doing cancer biology and I did a postto
there for 5 years before coming back to
Stanford and starting my own lab so the
type of research projects that my lab
are focused on really relate to the
changes in gene expression that occur as
cancers go all the way from when they're
you know a single cell that's just
becoming a Cancer all the way to gaining
the ability to invade into surrounding
tissues and metastasize so this process
whereby cancer cells can spread from the
primary tumor we actually work both in
lung cancer and then now more in
pancreatic cancer trying to understand
these sort of underpinnings of cancer
progression I'm passionate about
genetics I think there's just so many
unanswered questions and I think we're
really at a time now where we have so
many tools so many new tools where we
can really start to try to understand
these processes even when I was doing my
PhD in Immunology you know what I really
liked was the idea that even if we're
studying a model organism you know we're
doing these certain type of experiments
you can see the applicability to people
and I think you know the type of cancer
biology we do is really in that same
sort of area where you can just
immediately sort of see well if we can
understand this you know it could you
know have an impact on on
humans